all right it looks like we're now live
for another
live reading from my book uh reason
fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
always weird to look at it and see the
the letters backwards uh in the mirror
image that is this youtube
interface so
we have uh made it a good ways into the
book so far we are still in the first
stage of the christian philosophy
debates as far as the book is concerned
and today we're going to be reading a
short piece
by maurice blondell the third major
position
in the 1930s debates
much of his stuff had not been
translated which is why
i translated it and put it into this
volume so
this piece is called does christian
philosophy
exist as philosophy and it was a letter
in the appendix to the accounts of
meetings of the society frances d
philosophy and actually i'll tell you a
little bit about it
before i i read it
um so blondel if you don't know was a
major
philosopher in not just catholic but
also secular circles in france in the
early
1900s he's been kind of neglected since
then he's the person i actually wrote my
dissertation on
and um
by the time that these debates were
taking place in the early 1930s blondel
unfortunately
had gone nearly blind
and was working with the help of a
secretary so he kept everything up in
his head
and had to respond to things basically
orally you know he would dictate and he
would have things read to him
and so he got a hold of jillson's
presentation
in its early form
and i don't remember exactly what the
story was but it did involve a little
bit of
you know things not being quite
according to the way procedures are
supposed to go
and so he got uh jill stone's thing
ahead of time and he responded to it in
this letter which then was read
at the society frances d philosophy and
it ticked off jill sohn so much that
jill stone would not interact with him
after that and left the critique of
blondel as jill so writes in some of his
letters up to jacques martin who does in
fact critique blondel's position
in his essay on christian philosophy so
no further ado
i'm going to read this shortish
piece
it is about
okay so it's about
nine pages
uh it probably won't take us too long to
get through it and then i'll take
questions comments that sort of thing
afterwards
so here we go employed rarely in the
past thrown around too frequently in
certain contemporary milieus the
expression christian philosophy calls
for a critical examination
and to eliminate abusive uses
summary negations imprecise and
equivocal adherences as as mr zhilson
has done is to do us a great service
there is no use returning to the
distinctions his initial analyses
rightly and firmly established
one might perhaps desire certain of his
formulations be made less rigid
to suggest as he does the idea that the
thomist philosophy is extrinsic to
christian data so that it is established
in its rational enclosed stability that
is it seems without his realizing it an
excessive and historically unfaithful
thesis we will soon see why
and to interpret the expression
christian philosophy and saint
augustine's work as a denomination
antithetical to pagan philosophies
without there being an outline of an
intrinsic determination and a
specifically catholic synthesis in his
works
that is it seems an oversimplification
refuted by many texts and by the general
intention of the doctor of interior
illumination and intellectual humility
so in the end his summary of the very
various theses attributed to augustinian
seems at times tendentious and remains
incomplete we will soon provide an
example
but it is more worthwhile to bring our
efforts to bear on the technical problem
truly needing to be set out in full
precision and formal rigor
first
no philosopher we believe can
legitimately contest the preliminary
conditions mr jill stone sets out
seeking a correct expression and an
explicitly philosophical solution to the
problem
if there can be
properly speaking a christian philosophy
it is necessary both that the
spontaneity of the investigation remains
evident complete free
and that the contributions of history or
of religious experience can be
transformed into intelligibly
assemblable concepts
we fully accept these necessary and
salutary requirements and we freely
admit our hope to remain more docile in
the end than even those who reproach us
with lacking docility
in his review of the christian doctrines
of the past mr jill so attempts to
detach the litigious expression
christian philosophy from the thomas
tradition in order to reattach it all
the more if not exclusively to the
augustinian tradition
among those he names augustinian he
enumerates three main accepted senses of
the words christian philosophy according
to him the last would consist in
bringing the effort of christian
philosophy back onto the plane of the
concrete and using religious experience
without concept as a matter elaborated
thanks to actions mediation by life
without reflection being able to analyze
this mixture of the two heterogeneous
orders of nature and grace in short
without this confused concrete or this
experimental imminence being able to be
analyzed and raised to ideas that is
without being compatible with the quote
only conceivable philosophical
translation
i do not know which author he has in
mind here
nor
where this thesis so summarized as the
only one that would have tried to go
beyond the historical plane to supply a
speculative justification of christian
philosophy might have been maintained
in any case such a critical exposition
is totally foreign to my interpretation
recently presented in the
review to metaphysique october december
1930 page 468.
this use of augustinianism mr jill
attributes anonymously to some recent
augustinian does not fit it goes without
saying
the true attitude implicit or explicit
of augustine himself
and is equally foreign to the
philosophical and religious work i have
attempted on my part
it is not a matter anyway of augustine
or of those who as mr jill so
excellently notes have often wrongly
invoked him neither to him nor to to
them did i owe my thoughts initial
thesis or its development
according to the rules of historical
method in order to call itself christian
a doctrine should have to attach itself
directly to the primitive stimulation
not to commentators or to intermediaries
is it not strange to see christian
philosophy in philosophers professing a
doctrine that bears the restrictive
characters of their intellectual
personality and their particular
horizons
if christian philosophy and the precise
meaning of the term can exist it must be
christ and not a disciple it invokes
and thereby
our problems paradox is better displayed
for christ is not at all a philosopher
or a master of rational speculation
precisely there the difficulty to be
elucidated resides not in the later
debates between augustinians thomas
scotus or others
here's a footnote from blondel i have
never taken or invoked on my account the
appellation christian philosophy if i
use it here it is by accommodating
myself to the current terminology and to
defend under this contestable mingling
of words a cause that appears essential
to me and the next caed to the nouvelle
journey number 20 to be published at the
end of 1931
i devote 200 pages to this same problem
and i indicate why the expression
catholic philosophy would be more
rational and more exact
inexp appearance restrictive it aims at
what is universal in the salutary
disposition of thought and life even
ignorant of christ and at what in the
presence of revelation prepares and
justifies the ratsuna bile obsequia
all right so end of the footnote
but before articulating with exactitude
this paradoxical question from a point
of view that is strictly philosophical
but does not cease to be universally
christian and catholic in the two senses
of the term
we must seek
why
and how mr gilson transposes this
essentially doctrinal problem onto the
exclusively historical plane the sole
plane in his assessment where quote the
problem could be raised
whereas it seems to me to be to the
contrary that on a purely historical
ground
the question can receive only an
equivocal and doubly regrettable
solution
two presuppositions
invisibly bar the path to the very
possibility of christian philosophy it
is important therefore to set both of
them into a direct light and to indicate
why they are contestable for between
them in this philosophy there is a
formal incompatibility and therefore an
option imposes itself
the first of these presuppositions is
this philosophical doctrines as
different as they may be ultimately aim
at sealing themselves off in closed
sufficient and exclusive systems these
systems organize themselves with and
terminate in concept and all that does
not succeed in being raised to concepts
repulses philosophy
but this is precisely what is in
question
can it not be philosophical is it not
conceivable is it not even normal that
philosophy opens ulterior perspectives
holds the springboard ready so to say
but orients and stimulates spiritual
life's dynamism by posing
inevitable
problems whose complete solution it does
not provide even though it serves not to
allow them to be misunderstood nor
falsely resolved
the alternative is serious enough
perhaps surprising enough for it to be
necessary to emphasize it for a moment
and to ward off ambiguity
and all misunderstanding
when we speak of an open philosophy and
one that at the same time recognizes its
limits by being ready to accept ulterior
data
it is not a matter of an always
deficient character of particular
systems that despite their relative
perfection of synthesis organic like an
artistic masterpiece remain contingent
and are always to be
surpassed it is not a matter either of
the perpetual renewal of the
philosophical tradition in general
always perfectable because it is always
incomplete
or inadequate even where it is sure of
itself and grounds its incessant
movement on definitive acquisitions it
is a completely different question
it is a matter
of knowing this
yes or no
philosophical doctrines at whatever
degree of development they make it to
can they
should they aim at being sufficient at
buttoning up according to an expression
of secreta and providing by themselves
as spinoza said
all the light and all the strength
necessary for thought and life
so that they would be even under their
transitory form the last provision for
the spiritual journey and the supreme
explanation
or
on the other hand
by reason by duty constitutionally if we
can speak this way
must philosophy end up
whatever the level of its development
may be
in recognizing how it is normally
incomplete how it opens in itself and
before itself an empty space prepared
not only for its own ulterior
discoveries and on its own ground but
for illuminations and contributions
whose real origin it is not and cannot
become
for this it is this second thesis
philosophically definable and
supportable that is without proceeding
from a revelation
that alone is in spontaneous and deep
agreement with christianity
if this thesis has not been distinctly
perceived if it is confused with the
other alternative previously indicated
if it is more or less implicitly pushed
away
it is not surprising that an intrinsic
concept a pure essence of christian
philosophy is judged impossible for this
philosophy has precisely for its
principle for its object for its effect
the exclusion of this presupposition
that infiltrates the majority of systems
even without them
realizing it
but there is a second presupposition to
remove
because we cling to taking account of
the expression christian philosophy too
current to be simply eliminated and
because it seems abusive to abstract
away the christian contribution in
civilization and in the general movement
of thought lacking a dogmatic method
another method gets proposed to us
and without taking a position on these
matters fundamental bases basis a
philosophical historical research is
admitted as possible instructive and
legitimate in order to respond to the
questions like these
has the christian revelation played an
observable role in the speculative order
are certain systems explained only by
elements imported from positive religion
has dogma as extra philosophical as it
is been generative of reason and of
philosophical initiatives
to be sure
some maintain that taking the terms
rigorously this method cannot justify a
christian
philosophy intrinsically philosophical
and intrinsically christian they
therefore point out that
christian philosophy does not correspond
to a pure concept because it rests only
on a double concrete reality that of the
philosopher that of the christian
who can cohabitate in a manner if not
intrinsic even if one complacently
agrees to that epithet at least imminent
and it seems this is to return close to
the position that in paragraph c is
attributed to certain augustinians while
refusing them a properly philosophical
value but looking at it closely this
complacency resembling a sort of renewed
concordiaism seems doubly compromising
to both to philosophy and to the
christian revelation
for under the cover of a clandestine
reconciliation this hybridization
conjointly abandons the essential
interests of both of them
in fact if history is an intermediary
provides data taken from christianity in
a mixture of public facts or private
experiences to the laboratory
philosophical reflection
it is by forcibly stripping the data of
their supernatural originality it
accepts them it puts them into its mill
experiments on them in its own natural
and rational activity
but then
what get called revealed data are
thereby used in an equivocal way one
seems to use them just as they give
themselves to be
but really this revealed the
supernatural is trans-substantiated into
human ideas
and moral experiences whereas in order
to remain faithful to the christian view
one would have to respect in these data
their specific traits that it is what is
neither discovered nor assimilated nor
acting solely by human lights and powers
in exegesis in apologetics and theology
itself the deviations
through excellent intentions of
historicism have been pointed out let us
avoid falling into a philosophical
historicism for history in the technical
sense of the term is not able by itself
to discern the supreme reality whose
vehicle facts and ideas grasped in time
and space are from such point of view a
clandestine mutation a trans valuation
risks emptying christian philosophy the
specific signification without which it
is only a deceptive brand name
conversely
by wanting to integrate dogmas ideas
ascetic practices mystical experiences
coming to it from outside within itself
philosophy that would not have
preliminarily opened in itself this
empty space of which we spoke by its
very care not to alter the supernatural
character of christian data
introduces a foreign body into its flesh
a packet of incurably wounding spines
consequently the solution that some
proposed to us by history and the
historical point of view seems to
misrecognize all at the same time
philosophies and christianity's vital
interests proper dignity and very truth
to pay such a price would be to purchase
the expression christian philosophy at
too high a price and it would be better
resolutely to renounce it
without abusing the attention given me
and without doing poor service to the
cause of catholic philosophy by
excessive brevity
shall i dare now to conclude by
indicating how it seems to me possible
to assign a definite concept an
intellectual value a specific function
to it
the first and fundamental idea it is
inspired by is one by which deschamps
archbishop of malin one of the
constitution de fides three redactors at
the first vatican council made himself
an interpreter
at every level even under the most
developed and most autonomous forms
philosophy raises
ins inevitable problems it serves to
define to render precise to turn away
from false paths to equip against
abusive extrapolations
these problems on which philosophy has
the role of maintaining a continual
watch problems that are always
justifiable always urgent philosophy
also has the duty to show them in its
own light and by its own critiques not
as insoluble insoluble
but incompletely resolved by philosophy
whether in the
speculative order or whether for the
practical solutions they invoke
razionem
said one ancient philosopher following
this light
profiting from the speed acquired by the
very drive of philosophical
investigation we do not remain in the
presence of a black hole of an ocean for
which neither ship nor sail would seem
possible the empty space that we spoke
of earlier is not a chemerical fiction
projection of restlessness sickness of
the soul it has if one may say it
contours to discern a reason for being
to meditate on and to render rationally
admissible
and attractive and imperious character
but to which we should not give in by
vertigo and without having a right of
looking into that abyss
we do not have to throw ourselves in
there with our eyes closed
and on what should our eyes remain open
here then is the second specifying
character of catholic philosophy
the objection was made to us that in the
presence of christianity philosophy can
be in contact with it only by practices
mysterious mediation as if we had to
annihilate
our intellectual effort and grasp only
and solely man in his concrete state by
including in his religious life and jill
so adds philosophy that faithfully
translates the christian man's
experience is necessarily christian well
no
it is not a matter only of a vital
imminence who obscure secret the
believer or the practitioner would alone
possess for himself it would be
impossible for him as well as for others
to discern the real origin of what is
hidden in consciousness in the
subconscious or the unconscious and the
door would remain open to every
subjective illusion
to the contrary it is a matter of
considering with all the requirements of
the most intellectual critique the
advances the responses the claims the
interventions of this supernatural whose
possibility one must recognize and about
whose reality one must discern whether
in fact it is even under the most
paradoxical incarnations
and perhaps then one perceives that the
supernaturals at first disconcerting
demands correspond intelligibly to the
spontaneous requirements of this
autonomous open philosophy we described
above
without the first of the principles that
serves to raise the problem and this in
the intellectual order historical
solutions and christian teachings could
not be philosophically admissible in the
organism of rational thought
outside of this two union of two
principles that have just been
articulated
there seems to be no means to justify
the contested expression there are not
in the plural several christian
philosophies there is to reappropriate
an expression of saint justin the
philosopher the philosophy according to
christ in the singular that which
without usurping the content of any
dogma
sustains the intellectual atmosphere
where the divine life and man can
breathe
no again christ is not a philosopher
but precisely because of that he leaves
to human doctrines an immense
field to explore
he liberates philosophy from the
narrowness of systematic pretensions
by that by the conception he gives us of
the truth of the life of the way to
follow of the end to attain he requires
a dynamic idea
and he places philosophy in the face of
this gap coming from above that a thomas
theologian recently indicated to us and
many others by analyzing the intellect's
congenital requirements and establishing
quote the place of the supernatural in
the very philosophy of saint thomas
in father gui de broglie's articles it
is only
it is a matter only of an intelligible
possibility of an ideal reality if one
may say so inherent to the mind itself
but christian philosophy
must go further than this starting point
that is necessary to it but not
sufficient once christian philosophy
considers this speculative possibility
to be actualized in facts this is what
would need to be examined more closely
by making use of historical data in
philosophy's intellectual organism just
as mr joseon rightly demanded
how is the insertion conceivable and in
what ways can facts that by the very
hypothesis are inaccessible to direct
consciousness or unpredictable by
rational speculations
enter into our thought without
denaturing themselves and without
violating thought itself
these are not like simple facts of
consciousness like psychological states
like experimental verifications where
such data can be directly discerned and
related to their origin to their
signification to their destination
there lies the error of the doctrines
that claim to found themselves on vital
imminence and religious experience
if there is a supernatural order it is
unconscious insofar as it is such even
when it determines conscious states
philosophical integration of such data
can be carried out only by an
intellectual way in an indirect manner
but one that can be rendered explanatory
maul baraj said speaking of christian
truths that in the intelligible order it
was his own experiences as are the
positive experiences of the scholars
that are to be raised into laws and
explanations
in order to help us understand this
delicate invisceration of christian
facts in the philosophical organism and
in the interior open space or the
silence of the soul that the most
intrepidly rational speculation on the
mind's requirement and scope is prepared
for these facts
let us employ a simple allegory
songs strike my ear i do not hear the
words they are nevertheless present to
my hearing
let the libretto be set before my eyes
then by understanding it i hear what i
already really heard but without
understanding it is by intellectual
knowledge that i come indirectly to the
direct perception that the most
attentive experience did not succeed in
revealing to me
so it is with that religious life about
which some rightly raise the objection
it is not sufficient to transform itself
into a concept
but this mysterious song that the soul
does not know how to interpret in itself
completely real as it may be takes on a
truly intelligible meaning and the value
of a philosophical response when
doctrinal teaching sets the givens of
fact and the very requirements of the
mind in communication
so that's the end of this short piece
does christian philosophy exist as
philosophy maurice blondel's first
contribution to the debate uh going
after jill so a bit uh the next one is
there a christian philosophy published
in the review of physique
he's going to be responding to brahir
and so what we see is now several
different positions on what christian
philosophy could mean and what it would
require and how it would work being
sketched out within the structure of
these debates so it's no longer just two
sides the uh you know apologists for
christianity and the rationalists now
we're actually seeing splits appear on
the christian side of it between uh jill
so and mara 10 on the one hand and
blondel on the other a split that uh is
is to some degree you know it's not that
it's unnecessary but it didn't have to
turn into as big of a division
as it did and some of the other people
that we're going to see discussing
things in here
are going to be highlighting the
compatibility of the two positions
the other thing that i'll mention about
this is we're going to see a lot more
blondel coming up in this because he was
one of the um
largely in terms of translation on
disregarded
interlocutors in the debate one of the
first importance
but we're also going to see more
elaboration of this philosophy of
insufficiency the philosophy that opens
up within itself an empty space
needed to do that this is a
metaphilosophical
point of view as was julson's point of
view as was brahirs these are
philosophers
talking about philosophy its relation to
history its relation to the very complex
whatever we want to call it that that we
we call
christianity
so um
all that said i will you know take
questions comments about the
book
topics thinkers
it's not a general ama so you know i'm
not going to
do every every sort of question if
people have things that they want to ask
about
i'm happy to stick around for a bit
we're at the half hour mark at this
point
otherwise i will
bring it to a close and see you the next
time when we take up lone dell again so
any questions
comments issues
queries
people are saying hello so i'll say
hello
in not in advance with the opposite
after the fact
so
all right well
oh andrew asks a a big
not historical question like about
history but about my little own own side
history you could say what got you
interested in the christian philosophy
debate
so
i was doing work on rhys blondel you
know quite quite a lot of work led to my
dissertation and i
um
ran into a guy at a conference in 2000
named adrian pabst and it was a
conference um
with the university of lancaster that
eventually culminated in a book i i
contributed a chapter on blondel's
method and darida's method and showed
how they they were connected together
um
and how blondel was doing what daridah
was doing without some of the
excess commitments about a hundred years
well not quite a hundred years before
derrida brought it up um
80 years before that
and
pampste and i started talking back and
forth
and then he mailed me
a few of the documents that would later
be in
this book so the fair non-fund
steinbergen
piece
blondel's response to it
um so
von steinberg had the society's second
day of studies in the notion of
christian philosophy blondel had for an
integral philosophy and then he also ema
he mailed me the
copy of the uh a photocopy of the um
associated frances de philosophy
session from 1931 and he was like maybe
we should translate this stuff and then
of course he got busy
and sort of dropped out of the scene
and as i started following up on
the
texts that were footnoted
in uh
von steinberg
excuse me
article
i came to realize that the debate was
way bigger than
what most anglophone
philosophers largely in catholic circles
were portraying it as they they were
portraying it as
jillson and moritan against um the
rationalists or against von steinbergen
and they're almost totally ignoring
maurice blondel
which wasn't a surprise because blondel
you know uh hadn't been translated all
that much
um jillson mara 10 had basically gotten
to teach a couple
cycles of students over here and had
many followers and so people believed
their story about the debates and didn't
didn't dig any further
so as i started doing research i was
like
wow this is a really significant
set of debates that are taking place
maybe i should translate more and more
of this stuff and i you know i started i
did a lot of my research at the
university of notre dame's hesburgh
library
and i ended up photocopying basically
like two bankers boxes worth of uh
materials from journals and and books
from that that time
and it became clear to me after a while
that there were about 50 different
people involved in these debates that
spanned from 1931 to 1936
and that you know it would be good to
work on this and and translate it so
that's what i did and it was one of
those you know dynamic things where the
more that you research the more
interesting and exciting it gets to
realize that you're like opening up a
territory that you know french
french writers knew about because they
could read it in french and
english speaking uh
uh
thinkers really didn't know that well
including some big heavy hitter names
like joseph owens who
doesn't know the debates very well right
he writes about them
um and he basically muffs them you know
and so you know finding that out and
then and then
continuing with the work that ultimately
leads to this this book which doesn't
translate all the documents just a
portion of them
uh it became kind of an obsession for me
you know
so
ricky asked he mentioned st thomas he
did indeed mention saint thomas just
about everybody mentioned st thomas in
one way or another in the uh the debates
uh he's a main referendum
unsurprisingly given the importance of
tomism
in the 20th century was 1930s so
all right any other questions comments
queries about the book about um
you can't call them characters as such
but they're kind of like characters
uh the issues
i'll take a little drink while i'm at it
all right well i think we'll
bring it to a close then and um reminder
next time we'll be reading some more
blondel another short piece and then
we'll be moving into the
second phase of the debates where more
voices get added to
it's not quite a chorus it's more like
an argument taking place in a room with
lots of people chattering at each other
so thanks for joining me for this live
reading from my book uh
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
and i will see you
on another one of these sessions
you